senti que cette année plus de 30
millions de touristes vont visiter new
york comme paris l'une des destinations
les plus prisées au monde
depuis quelques années le ghetto noir
des années 60 harlem cherche à capter
les visiteurs le gospel
il devient presque une attraction maryse
burgot en ce dimanche matin les
new-yorkais ne sont pas encore réveillé
mais les touristes ou sont fin prêts en
france ils sont français ils ont déjà
visité new york les célèbres buildin et
la statue de la liberté
aujourd'hui leur programme c'est harlem
au quartier arlene le célèbre ghettos
noirs du nord de manhattan
au delà de 130 par les blancs de new
york n'aurait même pas l'idée et encore
moins l'envi de se promener dans harlem
et s'il se trompait car un dimanche
harlem est un jour béni les chapeaux
sont d'ailleurs à la hauteur de
l'événement le dimanche
arlene c'est en famille que l'on assiste
à la messe et 7 mai sma ces quelques
blancs ne l'oublierons sans doute jamais
la ferveur et l'enthousiasmé était ainsi
tous les dimanches matins dans les 600
délit baptiste de harlem
là bas au fond de l'église nos touristes
français en sont stupéfaits pour moi ça
va tu attends vraiment ford de mon
séjour à new york
je crois que je m'en rappellerai il faut
participer à la bonne heure tout à fait
différemment des français qui s'arrête
en pâtit au début ils n'ont fait que
regarder écouter puis le rythme des
gospels les uns en force et c'est gagné
ce tourisme des messes est aujourd'hui
devenu un énorme business
une trentaine d'agents sa new york se
partagent ce marché et les habitants de
harlem sont plutôt fier qu'on
s'intéresse à leur culture et pas
seulement au taux de criminalité dans
leur quartier m
il adore la musique ils applaudissent
ils sont debout comme nous entre autres
à travers l'église l'image et la
réputation de harlem est en train de
changer
le ghetto noir des années 60 devient peu
à peu un quartier fréquentable même pour
les blancs
enfin